khan is with us here in the studio lots
to talk to you um about mr khan mr murr
thank you for joining us but first of
all um i don't know if you've seen the
pictures of the mum
and baby that were carried out of the
mario paul uh maternity hospital i mean
lots of tears shed
not just in mariopol and wider ukraine
but right around the world this morning
for that young woman well it shows in
the the worst possible way the
consequences of putin's actions there
are consequences in relation to the
suffering
uh that we're seeing for in ukraine 2.4
million
ukrainians have fled
uh ukraine many uh not able to and we're
seeing the consequences of putin's
aggression that's why it's so important
for the rest of the world to be united
in relation to our condemnation in
unequivocal terms about what putin's
doing but also providing support without
question oh without doubt without a
doubt and some of the evidence we've
heard and read
in relation to uh
the allegations of the weapons used some
of the targets aren't allegations we
know some of the targets civilian uh
targets according to the definition is
there war crime
the russian embassy
in the uk here in your city said that
was fake news
well look i think it's really important
for us to push back in relation to what
the russian embassy is saying what putin
spokespeople are saying reminded of
a comical ali uh during the previous
war and outrageous behaviour it's really
important for us not to accept
what's been said by spokespeople and
puppets of putin and pushback
kamikaze of course who was the
spokesperson for the government um at
the time i think everyone who doesn't
even know that name can figure out why
he was called that um are we doing
enough for ukrainian refugees here in
the uk and what are you doing in london
well firstly i'm full of admiration for
those londoners who already are stepping
up to offer their homes for those who
will be leaving ukraine councils are
really able willing to step up hotels i
will enable step up businesses i will
enable step up there's two big parts of
the equation missing though one is for
the government to provide a simple
system of allowing people to come to
london and the uk and secondly is the
certainty in relation to support we need
i'll give you some of the examples some
of those people in the images you've
shown who will have seen that in real
time in ukraine will be coming to london
i'll be traumatized of course so the
wraparound support is really important
in relation to medical assistance
relation to helping the schools take
some of these children in relation to
the support needed around housing and so
as soon as the government can speed up
the visa process visa speed up people
come in here but secondly provide the
certainty of support the sooner we can
start re-housing those who are so
desperate in relation to their own
safety and that of their family too and
what do you say to those who say we you
know we can only take a finite number
because we're an overpopulated little
island and we don't have enough room i
think you're going to distinguish
refugees those uh who are seeking asylum
those who are leaving a war zone which
is what ukraine is with the concerns
people have look you know i think
germany's taking more than 80 000 people
france italy spain taking tens of
thousands of uh people uh
when you compare and contrast what we've
taken it's it's embarrassing as as a
proud brit
says we've taken more refugees than any
other country in europe well i i don't
want to accuse him of being a comical
ali but it's just not true i mean you
heard yesterday uh i remember the
cabinet accepting
that the number of visas processed not
the numbers who have arrived visas
processed is 3 000. i on friday spoke to
a number of colleagues across london to
get an idea of how many have arrived
because you get a good feel from
speaking to council leaders and those
across london
at best a handful our best handful have
arrived
even though it's processed is less than
the numbers we never arrived in mainland
europe from germany to spain from italy
to france yeah i was looking at some
figures this morning actually which
suggested that and these are just
figures that per uh refugee per thousand
population here in the united kingdom i
think we were behind sweden italy greece
uh germany france but the prime minister
says different well also listen i mean
the prime minister has done a really
good job actually to give him credit
speaking to president zelinski on a
regular basis that's really good we've
got to walk the walk now and we've got
to show evidence that we are willing to
you know lead by example that includes
of course providing the the the support
in relation to the donations
support food and medical supplies and
defensive weapons but it also must mean
uh providing a home a safe sanctuary for
those who haven't got a safe home in
ukraine and some women
in the capital don't have a safe home
are not safe when they're on the streets
what are you doing about that well i i i
say quite clearly and unequivocally i
think we've got an epidemic of male
violence against women and girls across
our country
over the last 12 months 127 women killed
the hands of men
i think that we've got to
recognize and accept i accept as a bloke
uh men and boys are responsible
for the sexism the inappropriate
attitudes and approach of improper
behavior that that is linked in my view
to bell violence and so we've begun a
campaign today working with brilliant
football and rugby and sports clubs
across our city
and uh there'll be a half time today in
the crystal palace versus man city game
the first premiere publicly of uh the
video and it's asking men to
you know have a word of themselves
reflect their own behavior have a word
with their mates challenge their mates
they may think it's banter
or just some jokes but how it's received
is very very different and the concern
we have is it starts with inappropriate
attitudes and behavior and leads to
a situation where you know
one every three days a woman is murdered
by a man across our country that's not
acceptable
what hope when those that are supposed
to uphold the law rape and murder women
well that that clearly is unacceptable
it's clearly unacceptable and that's why
it's so important
uh that the the new commissioner of the
met police service not only tackles
the deep cultural issues that leads to
too much sexism misogyny and
discrimination in the police
but also
wins back the trusted confidence of
women in particular and other minority
groups in the police service we police
by consent it can't be right that many
women and girls aren't reporting crimes
as victims because they lack confidence
witnesses aren't coming forward and it's
so important for us to have that police
and by consent model backed up
uh by demonstrating uh that the police
understand this is an issue and are
taking steps to address it
where are we forgive me as far as a new
commissioner is concerned so mayor's
office is working closely with the home
office in relation to the new
commissioner the appointment of the new
commissioner i know from previous
experience it does take a few months the
current commissioner is uh has agreed to
stand for a little while to help us with
the handover there will be a period from
previous experience where one
commissioner goes and the deputy
commissioner takes over before a new
commissioner arrives but the key thing
is the home office and i work closely
together to appoint the right person for
what i think is the best
but most difficult job in policing in
our country who will be telling us the
results of partygate will it be this
commissioner or the new one
uh i'm not sure i've deliberately stayed
out of the operational matters in
relation to this for good reasons i'm a
labor mayor uh allegations serious
delegations against a tory prime
minister uh you know i've not asked any
questions of the current commission
about the investigation because i don't
want any impression being given of me
interfering inappropriately okay i
suppose i asked the question because we
don't know how much longer it's going to
take before we get those results yeah i
mean listen many of us are frustrated by
the delay i think if the choice was
delayed but the right result or speed
and the wrong result we choose a formal
rather than latter